[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute but let's do it in a way that
makes the snowflakes heads explode let
me be clear before this podcast begins
we are loud proud and do not give a
[Music]
[__] this is the Tony Michaels podcast
real and raw political and social
comment AR the freedom to oppress the
rights of other people is not Liberty
you [__] eating [__] ah the smell of
freedom of speech this is the Tony
Michaels podcast and this is Tony
Michaels hey Tony [__]
[Music]
them so they're super pissed me got
booed at a football game in South
Carolina of all
and they're really mad they're really
[__] mad that we pointed out on the
inter whips oh the drama oh the drama
Tony why does this matter why does it
matter that he got booed at a football
game well it doesn't matter that they
got booed at a football game everyone
gets booed at a football game don't you
know
that I mean even Joe Biden would get
booed at a football game there's someone
there that would hate him that would boo
him Boo Boo this man Boo this
man but why it's so important in the
context of politics and where we're
going is because it pisses off the right
wing melts these
snowflakes into little piles of fascist
mush you know what I mean and that's the
most important thing that we can do is
mock them mock them to the coolest
extent I got into it with a little a
trollbot you know a right-wing trollbot
he thought it was funny that I called
him a right-wing
trollbot but the point wasn't the point
wasn't that I was getting into a back
and forth with a bot on Twitter the
point was is that they got [__]
pissed that he got booed and the reason
why is because they see him as a
deity no one cannot like him no one that
you're not allowed to dislike Donald
Trump in their
minds he can do no wrong there's nothing
he can say or do that is wrong in their
minds and that's the entire point I mean
we we all we as the pro-democracy
Coalition know that Joe Biden makes
plenty of
mistakes he's a
human he makes plenty of mistakes he's
made plenty of mistakes in his life most
people do you do I do we all make
mistakes it
happens that's why we're not in a
cult and when you see them look at a
video of him getting [__]
booed and then they're like no he wasn't
booed at all no one was
booing that means you're in a cult
you're in you're an a
cult when you can't look at something
and admit
what is actually in front of your
face because it is against the cult
leader you're in a cult that's what it
is I mean the today the Elon thing I
know a lot of people are getting all
kinds of [__] crazy because Elon is
touring Israel with BB Netanyahu as if
BB Netanyahu is some kind of grand
representative of the people of Israel
[__] Israelis are protesting that he
[__] resigned [__] that some
[__] hell some are blaming him
partially for being
neglectful of being so godamn right-wing
and wanting to take settlements illegal
settlements in the West Bank that he
took his eye off the ball and they got
attack attacked by Hamas from
Gaza some are blaming him for
that rightfully so maybe maybe not I
don't know you can [__] decide
they'll decide it's their country it's
their
thing but the fact that Elon Musk is
going on a I'm not I'm not an
anti-semite tour is really telling isn't
it this is what right-wingers do when
they get caught being anti-semitic
especially when it cost them a bunch of
[__] money which it cost Elon Musk a
ton of money and a ton of respect of um
amongst his blue check
Army because remember this was the whole
gag he was GNA buy Twitter he was going
to give you the ability to buy a blue
check when you buy a blue check all you
had to do was say racist vile bigoted
[__] on Twitter people would get inside
your thread in the comments and it would
be like a goddamn slot machine ding ding
ding ding ding ding ding ding d D ding
ding ding and then he would drop ads in
that [__] thread and you'd get paid
money for saying [__] racist bigoted
[__] oh man it was a great it was a
great model for Nazis to make money
online and all the advertisers like yeah
see we're on to you because Media
Matters pointed out that you're just
making money off vital and bigotry and
hatred anti-semitic rhetoric
you're just allowing
Nazis to profit off their
hate on X formerly known as
Twitter so now he's in Israel today now
if Elon really gave a [__] about Gaza
because apparently he's saying he's
gonna give starlink to Gaza like he gave
star Remember when he gave starlink to
Ukraine he's like oh yeah I'm I'm
definitely not for Putin I'll give
starlink to Ukraine then he's like oh
well you're I'm going to charge you for
it I'm going to charge you for it so is
he going to start charging the
Palestinians when will when will Elon
Musk start charging Palestinians for
starlink huh and will when will he
expect us the US taxpayers to pay that
[__] because you know Elon Musk lives
off taxpayer dollars all these people
who worship that [__] idiot who bowed
down at his feet oh he's the richest man
in the world he's so smart he's such a
genius
yes he lives off your tax hours he's a
[__] Welfare Queen you dummy what do
you think SpaceX is what do you think
Tesla is it's all [__] taxpayer
dollars that's been dumped into these
companies that's where he's gained the
majority of his [__] wealth in the
first place is us the
taxpayer and then as soon as he's out it
as an anti anti-semite and a right-
Winger as if he needed to be outed oh my
God and not to mention the lawsuits
against Media Matters for this I I I'm
I'm not surprised that Republican state
attorney
generals are suing me matters too and I
can't wait for the discovery Elon I
really can't I can't wait for the text
messages between you and Cat
turd the private DMS between you and Cat
turd I'm
serious if this goes to court which it
won't because they're [__] dumb it
won't go to court they can't let this go
to court they can't let the truth come
out into the open if they let the truth
come out into the open that would risk
them looking like [__]
idiots Elon the state attorney generals
all these [__] right-wing Nazis on
Twitter these these accounts that Elon
has propped up with his account and him
owning and him owning the
platform and a big huge dumpster fire
over there I don't know if you
noticed but this this is all one and the
same it's all one and the same [__]
where Trump goes to a football
game he shows up at a football game and
acts like it's his crowd and then the
trumpers online they get [__] pissed
they get pissed when he's booed because
it wasn't his crowd he just showed up at
a [__] football game again there was
a
micro Wing influencer that said Biden
couldn't draw a crowd like that that I
was like what the [__] are you talking
about couldn't draw a crowd like
that dude showed up at a football game
the crowd was there for the football
dummy that's what they were there for
they didn't give a [__] about Trump they
don't want that kind of [__] in their
football game in the first place most
people don't want politicians to come
and show up at football games and us
have to decide whether we're cheering or
booing for
them most Americans don't want that [__]
why do you think most Americans don't
[__] pay attention to politics and we
get all [__]
confused right I know a lot of people
are confused over the Thanksgiving
holiday a lot of people are saying that
Muslims in this country Americans who
are Muslims are not gonna vote for Joe
Biden never will I'll never vote for Joe
Biden ever again well this is dumb
[__] this is like chicken nuggets voting
for chickens voting for chicken nuggets
right this is dumb this is like women
for Trump that's stupid as [__] blacks
for Trump that's dumb as [__] dumbest
[__] I've ever heard and now Muslims for
Trump because they're never gonna vote
for Joe Biden this is stupid [__] I seen
many Assan post this stuff now Min Assan
isn't you know endorsing this idea he's
just posting that hey there's this
sentiment out there that American
Muslims aren't going to vote for Joe
Biden because his handling
of the conflict in Gaza what the [__]
are you talking about what the [__] are
you people blabbering
about this is dumb stupid [__] I mean
honestly I'm gonna show you today I'm
gonna show you uh Mike Davis now Mike
Davis and and I appreciate Nats girl
pointing it out in the producers corner
but I showed this clip months ago and
this is a clip that is months old of
Mike Davis a lawy
for all of you who think it's difficult
to be a lawyer out there Tony you're not
a lawyer you don't know anything about
the
14th Tony you're not a lawyer you can't
read okay all right no I'm serious
people are mad people really get really
upset when when when you can read like
the 14th Amendment and you can use your
brain power to understand how the
constit ution works and how it's not
worked and how it has worked and they
get really pissed off when you challenge
someone who is an
attorney I don't know it happens
sometimes but Mike Davis is an attorney
he's a lawyer he's a conservative lawyer
that's his you know that's his title
that he's given himself and I showed
this clip many weeks ago but this this
clip is months old and it's Mike Davis
the same Mike Davis that that has said
things about min mini
Hassan um said months and months and
months ago that yes we are going to
deport anyone who is brown we're going
to deport anyone with a funny name we're
Deport anyone of a religion we don't
like their grandparents their parents
anchor babies and he said they're gonna
lock kids in cages and him and Benny
Johnson are just
[Laughter]
like and I told you then I I've showed
it twice on the show and I told you then
and I said the second time
believe them when they tell you who they
are believe them don't [__] think
they're joking around they're [__]
they might be joking but they're
seriously
joking they're making it into a joke so
they can say it out loud and they can
test the waters they can see how it
treads on the
water and there's nothing more exciting
to Mike Davis and a bunch of [__]
Nazi lawyers and a bunch of Nazis like
Benny Johnson out
there then mini Hassan tweeting that he
wants or or that he's hearing from the
Muslim Community that they won't because
the Nazis are like yeah whoa you mean
you mean the people we want to
exterminate get rid of in this country
are going to willingly let us take power
so that we can exterminate
them that's what they're excited about
Mike Davis and the
Nazis they're excited about that
truly they really are now I don't think
it's the case right I actually don't
think that that's the case I don't think
Muslim Americans are not going to go
vote for Joe Biden they're pissed off
right and it's better to be pissed off
than pissed on but the thing is is that
you can [__] in one hand and want in the
other and see which one fills up first
and it really isn't going to cause you
much more than the decision that you
should already make
right wanting something so bad isn't
going to make it come to
fruition I want another candidate than
Joe Biden well that doesn't make it
doesn't make a [__] bits worth the
difference you can want all you want you
can go look at tyt you can go listen to
David Pacman you can go listen to Gren
Glenn Kushner about what you [__]
want right all the wants you want to
have oh man they'll give you all all the
[__] wants you want they'll lie to
you they'll give you misinformation
they'll tell you a bunch of [__] so
it makes you feel like you're getting
what you want oh what I want is
something that's not gonna
happen it doesn't make a shit's bit of
difference and my dad used to say that a
lot you can want one hand and [__] in
the other and see which one fills up
first and we're getting to that moment
right we're getting to that
moment that's why I believe in this
country
Muslims in our country who are going to
be voting in next election are going to
go vote for Joe Biden they're gonna go
vote for
him they are I I I know I'm kind of
challenging that sentiment but I want to
because I think it's all [__]
because if someone truly looks at the
two candidates Donald Trump and Joe
Biden and does deductive reasoning on
what those two candidates are saying and
what they're surrogate are saying Joe
Biden's not saying I'm going to send you
off the [__] camps we're going to
deport you we're going to get rid I
don't give a [__] if you were born here
if you're a certain religion certain
skin color and you got a funny name
you're gone
[__] and that's how it starts that's
how it's that's how that [__] starts
like another [__]
Holocaust okay that's how that [__]
[__]
starts Joe B ain't saying that [__] he
ain't even close to saying that [__]
ceasefire ceasefire now there is a
ceasefire guess who [__] helped
negotiate that
ceasefire I don't I don't see them
cheering it cheering it on apparently
they're going to get two more days of
ceasefire and I hope they get two more
days after that and two more days after
that and the killing can
stop I think that's what most people
want is the killing to
stop the problem is is Hamas isn't going
to try to stop killing Jewish people
they're not and BB Netanyahu is not
going to keep [__] taking settlements
illegally in the West
Bank he's
not so does it absolutely fix the
problem
no no you can want a solution in Gaza
you can want a solution in Israel you
can want a solution in the West Bank and
you can [__] in the other hand and see
which one fills up
first but if your idea
if your
idea anyone who's in this country is to
go vote for fascism because you don't
like Joe Biden or just stay at home
because you don't like Joe Biden well
then you're then you're supporting
fascism that's what you're doing I don't
give a [__] what your reason is I don't
care if you don't like what Biden said
about this or said about that or isn't
doing this way or that way or isn't
giving you what you want they giving you
what you want quit your [__] whining
quit your [__]
whining that's one thing I'm [__]
sick of is the [__] lebi such [__]
[__] do you know that we that that
when we do that we [__] play right
into their stupid [__]
hands we make it so easy for fascism to
seep into our democracy when we do that
stupid
[__]
what in the [__] does you voting in this
election for this country here for a
president of the United States have to
do have to do with what Joe Biden is not
even close to
saying it's a [__] lie you're
believing
[__] [__] is what you're
believing look at the truth look at the
action look what's happening right now
look at the [__] swaps it's a 3 to1 4
to1
swap and and you're yelling and
screaming about oh well we need to cease
fire because people are being
killed yet you you you won't stand with
Joe Biden and say goddamn he got he got
a four-year-old American Girl out of
hamas's hands [__] they even negotiated
that a woman who is in critical
condition get to the Red Cross and then
not cross to into Egypt and then back to
Israel but to cross directly from Gaza
to Israel which has not happened yet
during this conflict they negotiated
that they helped negotiate that you
people are wildly out of step with what
is
reality if you think if you think for a
second that you should not
vote in this country in our next
election because of something Joe Biden
said or didn't
say dumbest [__] ever because let me
tell you something I'm going to show you
footage of the of who Trump wants in his
administration saying that they're going
to [__] Deport you they don't give a
[__] if you're Americans they don't give
a
[__] they don't even consider you
Americans they don't consider you human
you realize that
right they don't consider you human this
is the same stupid [__] of a video I saw
and I'm going to show it because
right-wingers are spinning this stupid
[__] I don't know some [__] tick
tocker talking about how they found the
Quran and how they found religion and
Islam you are a dumb
[__] dumb [__] to think
to
think that somehow the
radicals of Hamas the Theocratic fascist
of Hamas are somehow the
carriers and the enlighteners of of
Islam you people are [__] dumb and
that you're finding religion because of
a bunch of [__] Theocratic fascist
you people are [__] wild out there
wild and crazy you got [__]
brainworms and you need to get your
Collective brain cells and rub those
[__] together and use critical
thinking
but again I'm very
optimistic Muslim Americans are not
going to not go vote they're not
because Trump is gonna make them go vote
for Biden folks he's gonna make him do
that because he's an [__] and you can
count you there's one thing you can
count on in this world and a lot a lot a
lot of the a lot of the women in the
chat know what I'm talking about when I
say this there's one thing you can count
on and you can count on an [__] being
an [__] ain't no you can [__] count
on it I mean almost
guaranteed it's a thing it's a
thing and I know this is a a long walk
from Trump getting booed but folks it is
the pot that we have to stir and we have
to keep stirring it and anything and I
tell you what oh man this footage of him
getting booed it pisses them off more
than anything else I've seen more than
anything else it [__] pisses I mean
they get
infuriated and the matter they are the
more
irrational they start to become and the
more irrational they start to become the
more obvious it is to people who need to
know that these people are irrational
and they're not using they're not using
deductive reasoning they're not using
logical thinking and they're definitely
not using critical thinking skills um
when they're trying to determine whether
Trump was booed or
not and when you get down to the skinny
of
it that is really where we need to be at
we need to show the country that it is a
cult and that if you are supporting
Trump you are supporting the cult it's
not about Republicans it's not about
politics it's about a Theocratic fascist
cult just like the one in Gaza of Hamas
that is supported and funded by Iran
that is supported by Putin isin't it
funny a't it funny how the Theocratic
fascist over in the Middle East that
murdered Jewish
people slaughtered Jewish people and
started this conflict that we have now
that is in a ceasefire as we
speak was funded by the same funer that
funds the Theocratic fascist the white
Christian nationalist here in this
country isn't it kind of funny it almost
feels like it's not exactly a
coincidence does it how was your
Thanksgiving how was your turkey day did
you eat turkey did you eat ham did you
eat mashed ters are you still eating
leftovers are you one of those
[__] eating leftovers on Cyber
Monday woo Cyber Monday whatever the
hell that means Cyber Monday everyone's
like yeah the big sales on Cyber Monday
I'm like what there's been sales all the
time the whole week what are you talking
about there's big sales on Cyber Monday
so maybe we'll go through that maybe we
won't but I want to tell you I
appreciate everyone who put in an order
over the weekend speaking of Black
Friday sales uh for the Merch this
machine kills fash year we're going to
do some more sales I might do a sale
this I might do a flash sale this
afternoon since it's Cyber Monday why
not maybe we'll do a flash sale this
afternoon for a few hours on merch do it
on the this machine kills fascist the
tattoo collection that's right I'm gonna
get this tattooed I'm getting a
microphone tattooed on my arm in January
that is inspired by this design you also
GI them my cat hates Ted Cruz or my even
my dog hates Ted Cruz merch just go to
the Tony michaels.com that's the Tony
michaels. don't go anywhere
we'll be right back right after
this we'll be right back Mark 60 seconds
this is the Tony Michaels
[Music]
podcast trying to remember all the
things you boycotted can really get you
stressed because there's no good way to
keep them from becoming a cluttered mess
well now there's boycott binder the
ingenious organizer that keeps track of
everything and everyone you've ever
boycotted the 72 category filing system
makes it easy to organize boycotted
people places and things so you can find
them with ease the large centered area
can even fit your boycott sign but best
of all when you're done the boycott
binder folds right up so you can take it
anywhere so if you're tired of having a
cluttered mess call now and get the
boycott binder for just
$29.99 plus you'll also receive our next
rep as a bonus just Loop it around your
neck to travel with ease but call right
now and we'll double the offer that's
two boycott binders and two neck straps
for just
$29.99 boycott binders brought to you by
the same makers of binders full of
women jumping back into it this is the
Tony Michaels
podcast
welcome back to the show can you tell my
voice a little hairy I'm trying not to
coughing to the microphone if you hear
the
microphone probably because I'm taking a
little uh cough break but I got my cough
drops here I got my cough drops so if
you hear the login in my mouth over the
next few days it's because I've had a
little bit of a problem it's no big deal
though I promise it's well it's sort of
a big deal
I mean I was you guys remember the
episode
um do do you remember the episode where
I lost my voice and I sounded like this
I tried to talk like this the whole time
and it it I I made it I made it through
this like a two-hour show where I lost
my voice and I made it almost all the
way through Gabe had to come in about
halfway and uh but we made it we made it
through and we're gonna make it through
this show how I made it 30 minutes
without coughing and I think I think
that is U is going to continue
so um big Stef fan says smoking too much
pot no no I did get eye a few times over
the weekend because I was sick so I I
was trying to you know rest a bit so I
did um Amanda says Alex Jones Tony
Michaels yes that was that was the Alex
Jones Tony Michel some thought I sound
like Batman hi I'm Batman and some
thought sounded like Alex Jones but you
know
whatever whatever whatever um we've got
an image here of chicken nuggets voting
for our chickens voting for chicken
nuggets here we go here it is here we go
vote for your nuggets vote for nuggets
vote Yes on Amendment one the Nugget
Amendment for
chicken it's so dumb
this is so stupid let me show you um uh
some of this stuff here I'll show you um
the tweet from Minnie Assan and Minnie
Assan is gonna show up a couple times in
the show today h for this little gag
here and then later on uh with Mike
Davis he's gonna show up because he's
Mike Davis said that he's going to if
Trump is
elected then he's going to um Deport Min
Assan he'd be one of the first ones
I guess I don't know I'll probably be
deported
too no I'm serious why wouldn't I be
deported why wouldn't they deport
me makes sense right I mean they don't
want me to talk so they deport me here's
Min Assan tweet he says I've had same
the same conversation with my Muslim
friends and family members over
Thanksgiving not a single one says they
will vote for Biden again having voted
for him in 2020 every single one says
it's because of Gaza demms need to
understand the anger is very
real Dems need to understand the anger
is very
real so what we should do what Dems Dems
should do and I don't know I I think
Minnie is talking about Dems as the
establishment not Dems as like
Democratic voters out there right
because I want to be very careful
because Min Assan is really one of the
ones on MSNBC that's worth a [__] he
really
is I mean he'll call balls and Strikes
right I mean I think so I think that's
what he's trying to do here and I and I
don't think many is actually like saying
he supports or endorses this sentiment
he just saying the sentiment exist
amongst his Muslim friends and
family this is really stupid [__]
though this is really stupid
[__]
as dumb as [__] if this is really a
sentiment and I said as much um I
tweeted back at many as if he watches I
think some some of the um MSNBC folks
watch the
show he's probably not one of them but
here is um here's what I said I said
this is so [__] stupid let's put the
guy in office that would send our Muslim
neighbors off to camps because that's
the truth Trump if he had his way would
send Muslims in this country off the
camps we all know that get the [__] out
of here I said if that is the truth then
there is more to it than what a
president would do about
Muslims if this is truly the sentiment
and this is what will happen which it
won't folks I'm very confident and I
know a lot of people are concerned about
this over the weekend and they're
concerned about the pro Palestinian
protest they're concerned about the left
being out of their [__] minds
by believing uh Theocratic fascist
propaganda out of the Arab world out of
Gaza at from
Hamas against Israel and it is there
there is something a foot here it's not
just what the president would say um
it's
anti-Semitism if you want to know the
honest truth I'll call it out I'll say
it right out in front it's not it's less
about what a president would do about
Muslims than the Muslims having
anti-semitic views I'm not calling mini
Hassan an anti-semite I do not think he
is he's not one he's I've never heard
him say anything or allude to that way
he would um that he is I'm I'm not
saying that at all and I actually don't
know that his Muslim friends and family
are either I have no idea but the
sentiment that there's really very real
anger over Gaza
towards Joe
Biden okay that's the key here then it's
not about what a president would do
about
Muslims
right so you know keep that mind and I I
think I think this
is H this is more [__] stupid
theater you remember um months and
months and months
ago um when we that we were going to ban
gas stoves you remember that every every
one of us lefties were like let's ban
gas stoves let's do it [__] them we'll
just piss them off we'll ban
gastos and they started yelling and
screaming they're banning gastos oh
they're getting ban
gastos which none of that's true none of
it I just made that [__] up none of us
said we should ban gases none of us
actually what happened there was a study
that was done that showed that that
gasos are kind of [__] dangerous when
you have them in the house like it's one
of the ways that families get carbon
monoxide
poisoning like literally that's that's
that's the one of the biggest dangers
it's one of the main appliances that
causes carbon monoxide po poisoning in a
household in this country and that's
what the study was pointing out like hey
it's probably a good idea if you don't
want to get carbon monoxide poisoning to
get an electric range not a gas
range and right Winger's like they're
going to ban gas do those wokers or some
[__] like that some [__] like that so we
sat and defended gas stoes and how we're
going to not do the G and of course we
had to mock it make fun of it and all
this [__] and it just got you
know it was just
stupid this the same
[__] same [__] same stupid [__] I know
it feels like Tony you're making you're
you're you're making the sentiment of
people in this country who are believing
lies and
propaganda into into believing lies and
propaganda about a stove yeah propaganda
doesn't give a [__] if the [__]
propaganda is about a [__] Appliance
or a goddamn War it doesn't care
propaganda doesn't give a [__] it
doesn't care and the Really the truth
doesn't give a [__] either the truth
does not give a [__] if it is about a
war or about a goddamn Appliance people
it just doesn't give a [__] the truth
doesn't care and eventually
eventually even though lies are a lot
easier to propagate they truly
are they truly are they truly are easier
to
propagate truth can be propagated as
well and truth always makes its its head
way out um Fred asked a question here he
says where would they send
Tony where would they deport me to they
wouldn't Deport
me they wouldn't Deport
me I
mean they would execute
me they'd have
to that's all I'm
saying speaking of that let's let me
show you this uh this video actually you
know what I want to show you a video
from
um from my neighbors manga Thanksgiving
here's a video from my neighbors manga
Thanksgiving since we haven't been able
to share Thanksgiving videos check this
out see if you think this is
real
okay how about that wow Thanksgiving
done all all they said was when was
Trump gonna go to jail and Grandpa lost
his mind at
Thanksgiving I don't know I don't know I
don't know what to tell you all right
let me let me go to this this clip I
just had that one in there look I'm I'm
I'm a little hopped up on cough drops
and musinex right now I'm trying not to
cough I'm trying to get the show done so
there may be a few faux Paws here but
I've showed this clip before Jason
Campbell posted this clip and this is a
Benny Johnson show I don't know if you
remember Benji Benji is a closeted gay
man who pretends that he hates gay
people he hates the LGBT he's the one
that went to Target and you know made a
big scene about how rainbows were on
[__] t-shirts and [__] and how it was
the end of the world remember that it
was going to be the end of our country
end of the world nothing was going to
exist after that because Target had
rainbows on [__] t-shirts or some
[__] you remember this guy this
closet that's right he's a closeted gay
man I don't have anything against it
whatever you want to do Benny I don't
care if you want to live in your life as
a gay man and a CL [__] if you want to
live openly or closet I know who am I to
judge I just don't want you Benny
judging other [__] people and telling
other [__] people how to live we're
not telling you how to live you're
living how you want to live you should
do it but listen to Mike Davis here Mike
Davis is going to be poised uh to be in
the project 2025 Nazi Trump Hitler
regime if if if the if Trump takes power
which he won't but he will uh if we let
him we stand in his way but here's Mike
Johnson listen to what Mike Johnson had
to say on Benny Johnson's show about
deporting people Mike I've never called
for lava to rain down from the heavens
but maybe upon Washington DC would you
be that sweet red hot lava for us I've
never been called sweet and you call me
sweet Ginger so I I think on men then um
Mike if you were questioning rather
Bennie Johnson is actually um gay or not
and a Claus the gay man did you hear
that exchange listen again but maybe
upon Washington DC
would you be that sweet red hot lava for
us I've never been called sweet and you
call me sweet Ginger so I I think I'm
then then um during my when does he call
him sweet Ginger like when he standing
behind him with his pants down or I
don't know [__] [__] I don't know what
what do you want from me I I'm just
asking qu I'm just asking questions I'm
asking questions Benny when did Mike
when did you call Mike Davis sweet
Ginger and then Giggle and then giggle
about it I mean whatever these two guys
want to do I don't give a [__] whatever
they want to do if they want to you know
call each other sweet Ginger and [__]
whatever they want [__] I don't even
care if they film it they put it on the
internet that's up to them they're two
consenting adults [__] I don't care
whatever they want to do well why are
these two wanting to deport people why
are these two people wanting to
exterminate people huh like three We R
of Terror As Trump acting attorney
general before I get chased out of town
with my trump pardon I will rain hell on
Washington DC we've talked about this
Ben I have five lists okay so I don't
know if you're catching on to this guy
but he's a [__] Nazi now I've talked
to this [__] yes I've sparred with
this Mike Johnson in a space with
Mario before he's a [__] idiot he I
mean just a coldblooded Nazi dumb [__]
nin kapo Nazi to the core this Mike
Johnson is but listen to what he says
about the port now they're trying to
make this into a joke but this is not a
[__] joke folks believe them when
they [__] say this [__] they're
telling you who the [__] they are listen
ready to go and they're growing list
number one we're going to fire we're
going to fire a lot of people in the
executive branch the deep state number
two we're gonna okay that's project 2025
that he's talking about there we're
going to talk more and more about that
in the months to come and if you want to
find a great video go to the library of
democracy again you can just go to
YouTube the library democracy there's
going to be more and more videos about
the Heritage Foundation and project
2025 okay uh but that's what he's
talking about there let's continue to
indict we're gon to indict Joe bidon and
H Bon and James Bon and every other
scumball SAS ball Bon except for the
5-year-old granddaughter who they
refused to acknowledge for five years
until the political pressure got to Joe
Biden okay so they're gonna do political
prosecutions right no evidence no
nothing Hunter Joe James every single
Biden Dr Joe Biden every Biden ow maybe
his dead son Bo maybe they'll resurrect
B and they'll [__] prosecute him too
maybe they'll just do that what are you
going to do about that kids and cages
there Mike number three we're going to
deport we're going to deport a lot of
people 10 million people in growing uh
anchor babies their parents their
grandparents we're gonna put kids in
cages it's going to be glorious we're
gonna put kids in cages it's gonna be
glorious I mean these people are you
know they're they they're acting like
they're half joking but they're [__]
serious folks I keep telling you this
and I know a lot of you are hearing me
and a lot of you are taking me seriously
um but and it's finally starting to leak
through we were talking about this on
the producers Corner this morning
that Joe Scarboro on Morning Joe and I I
I'll have to admit this morning I wasn't
feeling that well so I I laid down to
take a nap a pre-show
nap and I you know I usually listen to
Morning Joe on Monday mornings um that's
usually when I listen to
it just to keep track of what Joe's
doing over
there and someone mentioned that they've
been watching some more Morning Joe uh
lately in the producers corner I think
it was
Skip and um said said that Joe is trying
to be more tony like it feels like it
feels like he's come and listened to me
knock on him or there's a produc are
listening or something and so they're
trying to be more like Tony you know
have more like Tony Rants and they're
calling it outright fascism now now
they're not going as far as I go they
can't do that yet they can't get that
far they can't call them Nazis on MSNBC
they can say it's Fascism and they're
fascist and they can kind of toss around
the word Hitler but they can't say that
Mike Davis here and Benny Johnson and
Trump are [__] Nazis we're gonna
detain a lot of people in the DC gulug
uh and GMO and list number five I'm
gonna recommend a lot of pards every
January 6th defendant uh is gonna get a
Parton especially my hero hornman uh he
is definitely at the top of the paron
list the horn man he's talking about the
qan on
Shaman that's so he's talking about the
Horn Guy you know the guy War of the
[__]
horns
well it's a q andon World folks we're
just living in it and Mike Davis is
going to prosecute it so there's a
little bit of that well let me show you
um where uh he actually
said here right here um and Minnie's got
it here on his
account the double Saga of mini
Hassan
if I can get it here there there it is
Mike Davis the same Mike Davis
conservative lawyer and
activist okay he's a Nazi that's what it
should say underneath Mike Davis's name
a Nazi really simple but this is
Trump's 2025 plans to make this guy
that's right the guy you just listened
to talk about how brag about how they're
going to put kids in cages they're going
to deport 10 million people they're
going to send their political prisoners
off to the
goog are the gash with the Gestapo
police but the quote is Mike Davis vows
to jail and Deport Min Assan if Trump is
reelected so journalists especially ones
who are of the persuasion of many
here Muslim
persuasion are going to be deported if
Trump is elected because Mike Davis is
going to do that as the Attorney General
because he's going to reain hell and
wava down on DC after him and Benny
Johnson have made out for a while and
called each other sweet Ginger whatever
the [__] they do I don't know what the
[__] they're doing with each other how
the hell am I supposed to know I don't
give a [__] really I don't really care
what Benny and Mike do in their spare
time whatever they want to
do that's swell guys just leave your
Nazi [__] at the [__] door that's all
I give a [__] about so there you go
there's Mike Johnson and there's Min
Assan admitting that his that the
sentiment that the
sentiment um that he talked about over
Thanksgiving is really [__] dumb it's
really [__]
stupid it's really [__]
dumb because if you don't if you don't
go vote vot if Muslims in this country
don't go vote for Joe Biden anyone in
this country imagine as Muslim [__]
women young people Christians atheist
Jews whoever the [__] you are if you're
not going and voote for Joe Biden you're
voting for this guy to be the Attorney
General of the United States of
America to deport to
execute oh I'm I'm G be on the choing
Block too folks there's no question no
question I have living
breathing interest in democracy
continuing because I am so
anti-fas I am so [__]
anti-fascist that I have actual personal
interest into making sure that fascists
don't take over because when fascists
take over they they [__] kill
people that's how they they that's what
they and it starts with Talk Like Mike
Davis and Benny Johnson calling each
other sweet Ginger you know that's how
that that fascist [__]
starts I don't know if you know
this but if you've seen any kind of
1930s
1940s you a
documentary a lot of those Nazis a lot
of those
lot of those
dudes let's just
say you
know they're a little light in the
loafers not you know [__] I don't care
then bother me what bothers me is that
they want to get rid of people who they
are they want to get rid of themselves
self-loathing and they fall into this
trap of fascism because they hate
themselves
or some
[__] now here's a here's a clip let's
see uh comparing Trump and and Biden
what's look at this it's from Fox News
why not the Biden campaign put out a
quote handy guide for responding to
crazy magga nonsense this Thanksgiving
unquote and one of my favorite things is
a in the guide is the response you
should say if family members say Trump
is winning in the polls then they say
you should say something like oh those
same polls and pundits who said Joe
Biden would never be president and that
Republicans would have massive wins last
November and Biden is running on a
popular agenda agenda they tell you to
say and Trump is running on a losing
extreme one loser
interesting interesting that's all true
what what why why are you guys showing
the truth on Fox News why are you doing
this you see how do you see how it gets
in their
crawl do you see how you truly troll
them you see how mocking them makes it
possible for them to say the truth out
loud I mean we know that you shouldn't
listen to the [__] polls everyone
knows who's listened to the polls and
then watch the results and went what the
[__] the polls weren't even close to
what they were saying was going to
happen that happened it's not even [__]
close it's because you're listening to
the polls and you shouldn't listen to
the media the mainstream media you
should not listen to them on what the
American people think because they
definitely have no [__] clue and you
should definitely not listen to them on
no [__] polls their polls are
designed to stoke outrage and keep you
listening but if you want to listen to
something
wild and I want to show you something
here because this is a wild ride of
stupidity and this wild ride of
stupidity
here is what really is the problem in
this country now first off at first
glance you're like holy
[__] this lady's gonna say some wild and
crazy stuff right well you would be
right she is gonna say some wild and
crazy [__]
here
um but here is um here's some sort of
nonamer who put out a video now I want
you to listen to this this is like a
three minute video but listen to some of
the [__] she's saying and I'm gonna I'm
going to stop it a few times but this
is this is quintessential
kinon and this is quintessential
cultism because there's a few times in
here that she picks out real real
grievances right just little [__] [__]
that's true like she says stuff that's
that's kind of
true right and just kind
of and then she just soaks it in qinon
and conspiracy theory and and just dumb
[__] and expects you to eat it but
this is where they get this is how they
breadcrumb their way to cognitive
dissidence listen to this I'm sure
everybody heard last night that uh the
Irish basically played a game of [__]
around and find out and they lit up
their city and why do you ask because
Ireland are sick and tired of the
governing class who has let thousands of
these migrants and illegal citizens into
their countries and into their
neighborhoods and into their streets
where they've caused violence against
one of against their people and
you
am I am I muted am I muted did is is it
good now I don't know there's going to
be situations here over the next over
the next
um several days that going to feel like
um Tony's not Tony's not doing something
right and it's only because it's only
because I'm muting my mic because I'm
coughing yes I know I might have been
muted but let's go back to the [__] show
here you know what the governing class
and the police didn't do [__] about it
so the Irish did the Irish have stood up
against the governing class which is
exactly what all of us need to start
doing because more of this [__] is going
to continue to happen how much more of
our nation is everyone willing to sit
back and watch as it gets totally eroded
from the inside out so somehow somehow
she's taking a story which she doesn't
refer to much with the Irish in Ireland
and she applies it to what is going on
here really wild stuff crazy
craziness but you wouldn't expect much
out of this lady but here's the thing do
you hear the little bread crumb there
that is the truth right do you hear the
little the little bitty crumb of Truth
you know what I'm talking
about you know what I'm talking about
all right so you're laying in bed right
and you got you're under the sheets and
you feel this CR you're like there's a
crumb I know there's a [__] crumb
somewhere and you get up maybe eight
maybe eight you know something in your
bed two weeks ago I don't know maybe you
don't change your sheets that often
maybe you just ate last night right I
don't know but there's a crumb in the
bed and you can't find it you know what
I'm talking about you pull back the
covers it's bugging the [__] out you
there's this crumb you can't find it you
can't but you know it's there that's the
thing she's talking about here right
she's talking about how the ruling class
now she's aiming her ruling class in the
wrong direction right she's
misidentifying the ruling class in this
country country she thinks the ruling
class are are sick twisted Democrats who
want democracy who want decent [__]
wages and don't want people to go broke
because of a medical bill you know
that's the ruling class she
believes that there is so she's getting
that [__] up right so she's getting
that twist around but there's that Crum
of Truth in there there's that little
Crum of Truth it starts with the
indoctrinating of our kids and all their
classrooms and their schools it starts
with the TV and the programs and the
social media Talking Heads you see when
the left go out and Riot and deface
public monuments and stop Thanksgiving
parades from happening with their
[__] that's called peaceful
protesting you see but when the okay all
right all right all right so she's
talking about the Macy's Thanksgiving
Day Parade I think is what she's saying
I think that's what she's saying now the
problem is is that the people who were
protesting were Pro
Palestinian and they're Pro right-wing
Arab world thinking that's what they're
promoting I know it's weird that leftist
in this country think it's a good idea
to go protest for Theocratic fascist I
know it's [__] wild stuff but they're
doing it what do you want from me it's
their [__] freedom to be stupid just
like it's the freedom of of this lady to
be a total [__] bonehead that's what
Liberty affords us that's really the
risk of Liberty if you want to know the
honest
truth like to some degree to some degree
you're you start to think well at this
lady has the freedom and the Liberty to
be this [__] dumb and people on the
left on the left going and protesting so
that they can prop up the propaganda of
a Theo ratic right-wing movement in the
Arab
world doesn't make much sense but it's
not supposed to make sense Liberty
sometimes is not supposed to make sense
it's
not you just have to bear with it if
that makes if that makes
sense but it's her right to be stupid
it's their right to be stupid but what
she doesn't understand is the Theocratic
fascists that they are protesting that
thank Thanksgiving Day
Parade they think the same way you do
dummy those Theocratic fascists they
just have a different theocracy than you
do theirs is called Islam yours is
called Christianity it's basically the
same but it is I don't I don't know if
you know that but they're basically the
same uh almost all religions are
especially when they have one deity
but it's all the same God Jews Islam
Christian it's all the same God just a
different book just a different [__]
propaganda that they give you the point
is this is that this lady has the right
to not know that the people who are
protesting the Thanksgiving Day Parade
that she didn't like that they were
protesting they actually agree with her
in most cases but go on right does it oh
when the people stand up against the
governing class like in Ireland what do
they call it all the media jump on board
and what do they say rightwing rhetoric
now this is called the people standing
up and saying enough is enough and you
know what more needs to happen all of
you people that are like Palestine to
the Sea all that [__] I don't think
it's so easy to stand in the safety and
comfort of America where you know you
are accepted and perfectly safe by
causing nothing but chaos and
[__] oh see there it is see oh from
The River To The Sea she she do even
know the phrase she doesn't even know
the
phrase from The River To The Sea and she
doesn't know
that it is
right-wing it is right-wing fascist
theocracy see that's the weird part that
that's that that's the thing that we're
in right now we're in this position
where she is saying that she is not for
the pro right-wing fascist
theocracy but she is here she's not
there she is here and it's weird stuff
right because LEF is here are saying
weird [__] like that too backward stuff
and it's the reason why is because of
the [__] internet the [__]
internet makes these people think that
just because they puke up a bunch of
[__] word salad makes them [__]
intelligent and makes it where they
don't have to [__] know the truth you
don't need to know the [__] truth
what do you need to know the [__]
truth for all you got to do is believe
what you want to believe and by God you
got the truth and that's what this dumb
[__] believes if she just believes it
then it's true and people are getting
sick and tired of it how many more
videos you going to see of of crime
climate change protesters where people
have had enough and they grabbed them
and they toss them to the side of the
road and drive through more people need
to start standing up how much more are
we willing to watch our country be
eroded from the inside out by the
governing class who has let tens of
millions of people walk into this
country with no background checks no
money no housing and you and I the
taxpayers are gonna have to pay for it
how so like again she walks into the
truth a couple different times right
it's wild stuff you're trying to follow
her around and it's a wild ride and
folks you're saying Tony why are you
showing a video of this crazy cook
because this crazy C [__]
votes okay you got it write it down go
[__] put it on the refrigerator or
something this [__] bonehead [__]
votes she [__]
votes
okay yeah Trenton points out yeah now
she wants [__] background checks
right she wants background checks on
brown
people but she's not a right
winger [__] gobbly
go but she [__] votes
[__]
she [__]
votes and I know I know it feels like
well why do we got to watch a video just
about her because there's [__] all
kinds of these [__] running
around out
there they read the books of face and
they saw them some Tik toks and now they
know the truth and they're going to go
vote based on the truth how much more
are we willing to stand up because
Dublin and the Irish basically said [__]
around and find out and they lit up
Dublin last night against the governing
class oh Jesus I keep saying this we
outnumber them so how much who what the
[__] does that we outnumber them you're
such a [__] bonehead if you outnumber
us which that's what she's saying us
conservatives outnumber liberals if
that's the case why do you keep [__]
losing why explain us to it Karen why
more are we willing to sit back and
watch as our country gets torn apart by
the sickos our women and our women's
sports being pushed aside so men can be
in them here comes the genitalia [__]
they can't they can't give any kind of
rant without talking about [__] dicks
and vaginas in our safe places and in
our bathrooms and if you dare speak out
if you dare say no I'm not okay with
this as a woman well you're just a
hateful bigot right you are a hateful
bigot [__] you are a [__] hateful
bigot listen to what you're saying oh
this [__] has to stop and the only way
it stops is if more and more of us stand
up and stand together and say we're done
with the [__] Riley Gaines just won
a lawsuit of like $1.2 million because
she stood up among okay Riley gains
let's back it up here because this is
the part of the video where you're like
whoa what the [__] like this the part
I've been waiting for and I really kind
of wanted to lead in with this to give
you guys this idea but I didn't want you
to think that she was totally full of
[__] the entire time because she she
really again she's got that little crumb
you know what I'm talking about you
can't find it it's hard to [__] see
you know it's there though there's
something underlying there that is the
[__] truth she's at some sort of
level of truth that yes there is a
[__] ruin class in this country that
is [__] the rest of our
country just doesn't have her aim
right she's been convinced by qanon that
it's someone else so that they can
continue to [__] rule over
her she's a bone
head but this Riley gains I don't know
if you guys know this she's a she's an
athlete she's really upset Riley Gaines
is really upset about trans athletes
right and I to be quite honest with you
I don't know that that's not a place
where a reasonable debate can happen
about trans people and I don't know that
trans people can't come and have a
reasonable debate with people about that
subject you can't right now because
there's too many [__] Nazis that want
to exterminate these people you can't
have a debate with someone who wants to
exterminate you that's not a debate
people Jews weren't debating Hitler in
[__] 1930s 1940s Germany they weren't
debating they were being
exterminated you [__]
boneheads but R Ley gains did not win a
lawsuit she did
not the story that this [__] bonehead
is referring
to bear with me here because this is
wild stuff and this is not going to
surprise you at all when I say this this
[__] idiot
is referring to a
story in the D and Krueger
times let me say that
again this [__] idiot is referring to
a story
online from the dung duning krer times
I'm not kidding you it is satire it is
parody even in the [__] name of the
[__] publication this is like onion
times a
thousand
okay it's totally [__] satire they
don't push bones about it but these q
and honors believe this [__] that comes
from the Dunning career times all the
time I showed several [__] months ago
where these boneheads on Twitter were
believing that g Brooks had to cancel a
concert because he was
booed and it was that story was
published in the dunan times now they
published the story after G Brooks had
told people during the CMA Fest in
Nashville not to come to his bar if
you're gonna be a bigot they were all
giving him [__] about serving budlight
at his bar gar Brooks is a brand new bar
in um in Nashville it's called Friends
in Low Places of course because that's
his one of his signature songs and he
actually I actually watched the live
concert on Amazon he had a live concert
last Friday uh on Amazon I'm a big gar
Brooks fan everyone knows that I like G
Brooks I like 90s country that's my jam
and if you don't like it well that's
fine too that's fine you can judge me
all you want I like 90s country because
I like the singing But gu had a concert
opening up his grand opening for friends
and Low Places but months and months ago
back during the summer during CMA Fest
which is a huge event in Nashville like
CMA Fest is one of the biggest events
they have in Nashville
hundreds of thousands of people come to
Nashville just to come watch people sing
and have concerts and
[__] and you remember online there was
this big kafuffle about gar Brook's
selling Bud Light at his
bar and he's like I don't care if you
don't like me because I'm not serving
Bud Light I don't give a [__] if you're
going to be an [__] you can go be an
[__] someplace else and I'm not exact
quote but that's pretty close to the
quote is that if you're an [__] go be
an [__] somewhere
else but the dun and Krueger times which
is a satire website put out an article
that GAR Brooks was booed and they were
like see we got him cancelled we
cancelled gar Brooks he got booed out of
Texas and it's not it wasn't
real it wasn't [__] real but that's
the same done in krer times as she's
talking about this Riley gains article
listen more of us stand up and stand
together and say we're done with the
[__] Riley Gaines just won a lawsuit
of like $ 1.2 million dollar because she
stood up amongst the Sea of hate and
said no you're not doing this and more
of us need to start standing together my
family's lockedloaded and ready how much
more what's your Breaking Point how much
more of our country are you willing to
watch slide into recession while the
rich politicians get rich off of our
backs while causing and funling War
money of our money did she say
recession she needs to look up the word
recession the stock market's like over
35,000 what are you talking about
recession honey bun the [__] are you
trying to say these people are so
[__] goddamn
stupid God damn
it's it's [__]
ridiculous
insanity but she votes she votes votes
and you're not going to stop her from
voting right you're not going to stop
and you're definitely not going to con
look at her look at this lady you're not
GNA convince
her to vote in another
Direction hell to the no no way are you
gonna be able to do
that not gonna
happen but you you can
vote you can make sure your neighbor
votes your neighbors neighbor votes
make sure your family
votes you can engage in your
democracy that's how you fight this
crazy [__]
idiot if you don't get complacent you
don't you don't breed
disencouragement I've been saying for a
long time for months that this 14th
Amendment talk is going to discourage
voters
and it'll disengage the pro-democracy
Coalition I've been telling it to you
over and over and over again and people
got mad people aren't going to come
watch Tony anymore because he calls
Glenn out and Glenn's smart I don't give
a [__] how smart he is I don't
care I don't give a [__] how dumb she is
I don't
care
I'm going to call out when I see
it when I see it I'm going to show it to
you I'm going to show you why it is so
important that you
engage it's so important that you
engage because these [__] people have
lost their
minds they've lost their
minds they've lost it
and it is so important that you keep
every single bit of this in mind and
again she's quoting an
article she puts it in the
video from the Dunning Krueger
times just go look up the Dunning
Krueger times it's
satire they're believing satire and
believing that it's quotable all right
let's move on to Donald Trump getting
[__] booed in South Carolina shall
we why not why not here boo yeah [__]
him Boo this man Boo this man now here
is the
Billboard um that I put on the thumbnail
today you lost your guilty welcome to
Columbia
Donald put out by Jay Bender I
think um this was over the weekend he
showed up on Saturday South
Carolina Clemson was
playing and of course the right- wiers
are really pissed off about this oh
they're really upset and they're really
upset that we point this out let me tell
you something we should not stop
pointing this out we should not stop
pointing this out it [__] pisses them
off [__] infu Ates
them and we should point it out over and
over and over and over and
over and over and and over and and over
and and over again because here is the U
here's the one
video um that I like the most and it
shows the band but you see you see that
the the Secret Service here and they're
getting ready for for old grandpa poopy
pants go out there and do his thumbs up
and
wave right but listen to the crowd see
if you can hear the
[Applause]
boo the Clemson B they even giving him
thumbs
down dumbs down
boo [__] you bo boo like thumbs down
[__] this is not a this is not a crowd
that is enthused by Donald
[Applause]
Trump now there's a lot of booze there's
a lot of cheering there's a lot of
different stuff going on here
right but you don't need to know any of
that all she need didn't know he was
[__]
[Laughter]
booed just boo him just boo him just boo
him and say he got
booed because it pisses him off it
causes him to do things like this here's
another video that um someone posted let
me read this this is um um here let me
show
you here is um
Joy Reaper um she is a blue chick on
Twitter so she's an idiot uh let me see
if I can oh yeah okay so she's a wife
mother Bible teacher oh my God how nice
and kneee horse
breeder wh what she's a
conservative she's a forced birther and
she's Maga and her pronouns are
XX I don't know what that means those
aren't pronouns but okay all right let's
see what she has to say about this being
booed and she post a video here she says
so Democrats and DeSantis
supporters think Trump was booed last
night when
truthfully everywhere he's goes he's
treated like a rock star wow I guess
they
confess confuse crescendos of Cheers
when the whole Crow realizes who it is
chance of USA USA and flag weing with
booze as for
DeSantis he's already proven to have a
losing strategy so this denial is no
surprise well Democrats are never
truthful I this is [__] just it's
hard to read the truth is Trump is loved
and Joe Biden could never draw a kind of
this kind kind of crowd okay lady this
kind of crowd was not drao because of
Donald Trump there was a [__] bow
game going on you bonehead but watch
this clip she she
shows does it sound like they're
booing it sounds like to me they're
booing I mean there's some chearing
[Laughter]
now the the old [__] ball sack
standing next to him because
conservatives love old wrinkly ball
sacks we all know
that um he the governor of South
Carolina he's an old wrinkly ball sack
too because they think you know what I
want an old wrinkly bll sack to tell me
what to do especially Republican one oh
boy they'll oppress me really
[Applause]
good this does not sound like hearing
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you I mean there's some flag waving you
know as she claims but not not a lot I
mean this isn't overwhelming cheering is
it
[Applause]
and then she said here's the USA
chance but it's after he leaves the
field not when he was on the
field so he booed off the
field you know I guess that's my
point but I just find it funny that
these people think
that he went there and these people
showed up for him and not the football
game these people are out of their
[__] minds they're out of their
minds but here is here's another video
If this gives you a sense of how it went
how it actually went for Donald Trump
now this is the uh this is the limousine
pulling in holding Donald Trump and you
can see him here you can see him in the
limousine light right there but watch as
it just listen
[Music]
[Applause]
does it sound like they're cheering for
him I mean he's in a limo I'm not I'm
not gonna I'm not g I'm not gonna lie
he's already in limo and he's it looks
like he's debating whether he's going to
get out or not let's back it up just a
bit let's listen let's listen to the
cheers
[Applause]
[Music]
here
it doesn't feel like they're welcoming
him I'm mean I'm gonna be honest it
feels like a lot of
booze a lot of booze a lot of booze as
he's pulling in right he hadn't even
made it out on the field yet and they're
already booing him when they realize
that it's the fat [__] slob from Mar
Lago in the limousine coming out on the
field they're booing it
okay and this is the video that really
pisses off manga so this is the one I
want you to hold on to because this has
him in the shot and they're booing him
so make
sure that you play this over and over
and over again and you spread this
around all kinds of social
media this is Trump getting
[Music]
booed
and they're just booing
him there you go he was booed Boo this
man Boo this man so there's your your D
I'm gonna take a quick break maybe get a
few coughs out get a few drinks get
maybe another cough drop and we'll be
right back right after
this we'll be right back Mark 60 seconds
this is the Tony Michaels
[Music]
podcast are you numb and alone after
storming the capital have you been left
out in the cold after stealing Nancy
pel's mail do you feel exposed to a
government that doesn't share your
patriotic values if any of these
describe you then you're in luck hi I'm
Paul gosar and thanks to my new product
pardon blanket I've got you covered
paron blanket specifically Works to make
you feel safe and cozy after your
involvement on January 6th and if you're
one of the other members of Congress who
also helped with the attempted coup part
and blanket will protect you too Parton
blanket is made of a sort of soft fleece
and a layer of sheep's wool and they're
100% made in the USA don't delay and get
your pardon blanket today for just
$999.99 actual pardon's not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels
podcast I'd be very very der in my duty
if I didn't run laps and cheer for
something great that happened over the
holiday season I don't know if you heard
this but Derek
chovin George Floyd's murderer and a
shiv got into it and imprison the right
wing is really mad that he was stabbed
are you mad I'm not mad that is not the
last time that Derek shovin will be
stabbed in a prison by the way it's not
the last time that he'll be stabbed in a
prison listen Dereck chovin is a cop who
murdered George Floyd in broad
daylight because of an alleged fake $20
bill snuffed out his life with his knee
murdered him and challenged people
challenged people to stop him on
camera guy's in a federal prison because
he was convicted of hate crimes too and
he thought it was a good idea to go to a
federal prison he thought he'd survive
in there more than he would survive in a
state
prison but he got stabbed over the
weekend because he's a
cop that that
murdered someone because of an alleged
$20
bill it's why I got
stabbed
so and the rightwing is really mad about
it it will not be the last time that
Derek chovin gets stabbed in
prison it will not be the
last so they might as well get used to
it okay
speaking of getting used to things are
you getting used to Maga being morons
well my friend Walter Masterson uh is a
master and getting used to them let's
listen to what they want if Donald Trump
is elected let's listen so Trump has one
reelection what would you like to see
happen we would want to see a federal
and National ban on abortional the end
goal yes and have all of the pro-life
bills be um pro-life at
conception we're doing hypothetical
Trump wins the election what do you want
to see Trump do fire them all everyone
you fire them they come back in they
apply for the job and they got to have
theill not their color not their sex not
their perverted sex they just happen to
be black or they happen to be gay happen
to be you know a lesbian black person
that's not oh oh she doesn't want those
kind of people in our government they
just happen to be what what are you
talking
about there's people who are gay there's
people who are black there's people who
are lesbians it's a Thing lady it's been
a thing for a long time maybe maybe the
buttons aren't just in the Hat maybe you
should stop sticking the buttons in your
[__] brain there [__] but keep going
not qualifications but that's what it is
right now what do you want to see Trump
do first in office let the J Sixers out
let the J Sixers out shut down the FBI
we making sure that all children
regardless of their status in this
country are able to get nutrition first
and foremost the Republicans they're
doing this thing where they're cutting
school lunch program for little kids
that's that's completely
unacceptable first thing that I wanted
to do is to go the Border second thing
is I want him to lower the inflation of
this country that's really really high
right now how is he going to lower the
inflation well I guess by uh well that's
that's a good question according to this
chart what is the biggest driver of
inflation it would be corporate profits
what about for like education uh I
believe that they shouldn't make the
students pay back you know for the loans
oh so they student debt relief exactly
correct there has to be Cuts in spending
our national debts
crazy okay so you seen that there right
you seen the kernels of where they run
into it again folks I know it feels like
these people are [__] dumber than dog
[__] right it always feels like they
can't they just get dumber and dumber
and
dumber listen and I'm telling you this
is true that there are a lot of things
that they agree with us on
they just don't know it they're so
[__] far down in the Q andon rabbit
hole that they don't know it and they
got even further in the rabbit hole down
this week here's this same lady talking
about JFK Jr listen to this so right now
across Miami is the GOP debates or as I
like to call it the vice presidential
debates oh I wouldn't pick any of them
for vice president either who's a good
VP p in your opinion I I would say Jon
of Kennedy Jr but most people think he's
RFK Jr or wait no John JFK Jr JFK Jr yes
he didn't die in the plane crash no do
you know what was happening at the exact
time his plane crashed tell me
everything he was running for the Senate
I love that when wal's like tell me
everything tell me everything that you
know you crazy
[__] oh Walter oh my God Walter when he
just when this lady's like look man I'm
gonna drop the truth bomb on you and
Walter's like I can't wait for you to
say some crazy [__] into this microphone
lady give it tell me everything you know
seat against Hillary imagine that let's
rewind it
let's in the plane crash no do you know
what was happening at the exact time his
plane crashed tell me everything he was
running for the senate seat against
Hillary imagine that
his plane crashed while he was running
for office against
Hillary of course that is not true JFK
Jr's plane crashed July 16th 1999
Hillary filed for a statement of Canon
see for the senate seat in October of
1999 bonee
heads it's got a big body count yeah
it's you know that I didn't know was at
Rushmore when does this lady know what a
Bonnie count is does she know what a oh
she thinks she thinks Bonnie count is
how many people you killed not [__]
what a bonehead she really thinks that
Bonnie count means oh Jesus Christ this
lady okay keep going tell us everything
you know Trump was there July 3rd 2020
but they were all there at the event we
were at they said along with Jee ho who
is now the editor of George and Donald
Trump Jr and John F Kenn Jun were in the
helicopter and they let him off on top
of Mount Rushmore I have a picture of it
she has a picture of it she has she has
a picture of Donald Trump Jr and JFK Jr
and Jean H they're in a
helicopter on Mount Rushmore I was there
I got a picture I got a
picture my [__] god what the [__] but
over the weekend Twitter was all Blaze
about this JFK Jr stuff and the reason
why is because JFK Jr's
birthday so right was over the weekend
um so they had to you know the internet
had to do their thing and let me show
you this one video of this guy oh my God
this is great watch this [__] this guy
votes too by the way this guy votes this
guy votes watch has every once's been
wondering about if he's
alive it has three letters and Junior
after his name
[Music]
he's
alive oh my God it's all
true and his
[Music]
wife this guy's sitting in his living
room on the couch right he's watching Q
andon internet videos and he comes to
the realization
and John F keny Jer is a li it's true oh
my
God and this and this is what it looks
like this is what it looks
like when a cult member becomes a
cultist oh my
[Music]
gosh
and the the pictures that you're looking
at is the evidence this guy's
[Music]
te that's the [__] that he looked at to
realize that John F Kennedy Jr is is
alive listen there's no [__] hope for
these people there really
isn't there's no hope for these
people but there's hope for us
okay there's hope for
us we can't get [__] discouraged
because of stupid [__] we got to keep
our eye on the prize and the eye on the
prize is these [__] people are
dangerous this is dangerous
[__] this is dangerous
[__] [__] when you let stupidity run
a muck like
this and it gets dangerous because the
Dumber it gets the more and more and
more they hand
over our country to a bunch of [__]
fascists that are willing to send people
off to camps and to [__]
stoves I mean here's a [__] video
about the Macy's Thanksgiving Day Parade
I'm not kidding
you and this person is talking about how
somehow the parade is is about the LG I
don't know this guy's from the American
Family F Association which is should be
deemed a terrorist organization in my
opinion but let's listen one million mom
saying the annual parade will be um an
indoctrination essentially exposing tens
of millions of viewers at home to the
liberal lgbtq agenda um is what they're
upset about the fact that there is a
non-binary uh identifying actor who is
partaking in a song from the play and
Juliet I believe they're walking in the
parade oh my god did you hear what she
just
said moms all around the
country moms all around the country are
upset that there's a nonbinary actor
that's going to be in the [__] what
the [__] are you talking
about why are people so [__]
concerned did you I had no idea I
watched part of the Macy's Thanksgiving
Day Parade Thanksgiving morning with my
daughter and we don't get TV so I didn't
get to watch the NBC the real highly
produced one we watched some [__]
some shitty ass camera feed from USA
Today on
YouTube but it's not about what they're
saying about the parade folks it's about
what they're saying they want to do to
these people
listen there are two musicals that are
being featured in the Macy's parade this
year one's called an Juliet and if you
don't know the storyline the way it
works is Juliet finds out that her one
true love Romeo is actually not dead she
finds out in fact that he's basically a
sex addict that he's said had sex with
men women really doesn't matter the show
goes downhill from there the second show
that's being featured is basically lgbtq
Midwest style it's a show called Shu
that features uh a a crossdressing
biological male who is you know
non-binary as you said basically dancing
for kids you know for me for my family
Thanksgiving is about being thankful and
I'm not thankful to see a fat dude
dressed like a woman dancing around for
my kids it's not why in the [__] are you
watching it then why why are you turning
this [__] on if you don't want to watch
it why there's a [__] button turn it
off
dummy turn that [__] [__] off if you
don't like
it you [__] weirdo who is this guy
anyways I A lot of people are asking
this folks that's not the point the
point isn't that they don't want they
don't want these people to exist
that's what he's trying to tell you he's
trying to say it listen not safe and
it's not good for my kids it's not how I
want to spend Thanksgiving
Day yeah what doctor why do you think
they're pushing this on Thanksgiving I
mean of all days to kind of be
indoctrinating children Macy's
Thanksgiving Day Parade we've got the
floats out there you've got uh the
traditional uh holiday music it's it's
more of a Christmas Day many Day Parade
in in many respects than even a a
Thanksgiving Parade so why is this being
pushed so hard on Thanksgiving this is
very intentional it's because the left
is coming after people's kids they're oh
my God no you weirdo you who looks like
you're in some sort of [__] I'm not
gonna lie it looks like he's AI what do
you want from me it looks like he's AI I
I I can't I can't get over it I can't
get over it is
it
[Music]
I don't know I think he's AI I think
he's AI I really do but what what the
[__] does this weird this weirdo doesn't
want your
kids doesn't want you to have consent
over your kids that's what they're
really saying if you listen to what
they're saying listen to what they're
saying to
you okay okay most reasonable human
beings are like well I don't want my
kids to watch that so don't let them
watch it okay all right all right dude
don't let your kids watch it if you
don't want them to watch a Disney movie
I don't know why why can't you you're
literally seeking to groom kids it's
about sexualizing kids but what it's
also about separating kids from their
parents that's why we're seeing for
instance there's so much emphasis on
Mental Health counseling and things like
that
schols say hey this is a space where we
want to lock out your parents we don't
want your parents to know what you're up
to we don't want you know your parents
what you're thinking about likewise
they're targeting Kids In This Very
intentional way in these places that
used to be safe spaces for kids but
they're not safe anymore so we need
parents to step up we need for instance
folks to sign the petition at 1 million
moms.com we have more than 40,000
signatures right now I'm also with AFA
action we need folks folks to go to AFA
Action Sign up for our action alerts
we're doing concrete things around the
country to protect kids wait did you
hear that AFA action alerts.com listen
listen petition at 1 million moms.com we
have more than 40,000 signatures right
now I'm also with AFA action we need
folks to go to AFA Action Sign up for
our action alerts oh AFA action I wonder
if there's a place on there where you
can report pastors and
ministers that have been
I don't know convicted of crimes
indicted on crimes I know I'm just
saying like real groomers I wonder if
there's a place on there where you can
put it because this guy I'm not gonna
lie to you this guy Dr Jameson Taylor
Senior fellow at the American Family
Association AFA as they call it which is
a [__] anti-gay I I've listened to
AFA a long time for a long time they
used to have radio stations and radio
host they' have talk they have talk
shows and they would call gay people
[__] demons and [__] on their talk
shows they would call them monsters and
we need to eradicate them I'm not
[__] you this is who the AFA is and
the AFA the American Family Association
is a [__] terrorist organization is
what they are they are designed to
[__] breed Terror closeted gay
[__] out there self-loathing
and self-hating trying to exterminate
gay people this mother [__] Dr Jameson
Taylor the the prey the gay away didn't
work for him so now he wants to
exterminate [__] and they do it
through the American Family
Association it's what they
do they're [__] [__] always have
been [__] but they're telling you
the quiet part out loud we want to groom
your children and they're using
projection to do it they're acting as if
they're acting as if that parents give
giving consent for children to get
therapy parents giving consent for
children to get therapy is somehow
grooming and it's the parents losing
their consent you are such [__]
boneheads if you believe this garbage
and trust me boneheads believe this [__]
look at this guy what the [__] where the
[__] is he at this is not
real this is not [__]
real no [__] way is this real this
has got to be
[Music]
AI this guy isn't real right I don't
know look him up see if he's real [__]
this guy [__]
him they're coming after your
consent they're coming after your
Schools they're coming after your kids
education they're coming after all of
it all of it hell they're even coming
after your health care look here the
cost of Obamacare is out of control plus
it is not good health care I'm seriously
looking at
Alternatives
what you're seriously this is Donald
Trump talking here over the
weekend he's seriously looking at
alternatives
what dude you're not president and you
were president what happened to the
[__] healthc care week and the
infrastructure week what happened to hey
two weeks from now we're going to have a
great great [__] health care plan in
two weeks just give me two weeks it's
only two weeks away does he say that in
this in this [__] in this
post he says we had a couple of
Republican Senators who campaign for six
years against it and then raised their
hands not to terminate
it
Terminator it was a low point for the
Republican party but we should never
give up you hear that he wants to take
away your health care he doesn't want
you to have decent [__] Health Care
he wants you to go broke because of a
medical bill that's what Donald Trump
wants he wants you get a broke because
of a medical bill I'm not making it up
he's saying telling to Qui part out
loud oh yeah and and
and and those bidens oh man those
Bens but if you look at the president's
tax returns that he that he has released
publicly there's no documentation of any
interest income that he has received for
any loans that he had granted towards
anyone so we need what what what wait
what back that up back that up Jason
sent this from my state and he said what
about the tax returns that we what the
evidence that we have the tax returns
what do they says that he that he has
released publicly okay he's released
those tax returns publicly so what did
they say Jason there's no documentation
of any interest income that he has
received for any loans that he had
granted towards anyone so oh okay so so
actually Joe Biden was giving his family
interest free loans which you're allowed
to do you're allowed to do
that you're allowed to do that what
what why why are we standing around
arguing the biteen family
corruption if you are looking at the
public tax returns which we've been
trying to tell you this Jason Jason look
just like I've been telling you to just
come to the grips of the truth and tell
us all about your secret that you
got tell us about the other secret that
you got that's not that big of a secret
is that Joe Biden was lending money to
his family with no
interest oh my God you just you can't
make this [__] [__] up literally
Jason Smith listen to it again run smack
dab into the [__] truth but then
listen to how he rounds it out but if
look at the president's tax returns that
he that he has released publicly there's
no documentation of any interest income
that he has received for any loans that
he had granted towards anyone so we need
answers to those questions to make sure
that people are being accurate on their
tax
forms oh my God okay do you want to know
how James Biden didn't pay Joe Biden any
interest do you want to know how oh my
God I can't even believe I have to
[__] say this [__] into a goddamn
microphone for Jason
Smith Jason bear with me normally when
you loan someone 200 Grand okay are you
with me
Jason are you with me here Jason Jesus
Christ stay with me when you loan
someone 200 Grand and they go to pay the
[__] money back to you okay if
they're going to write you a check which
you claim you got a check that shows
that there was crime
committed proves without a Shadow of
Doubt the bidens are a corrupt
family normally Jason if there was
interest
paid dum dum the check that James Biden
would have wrote back to Joe Biden to
pay off the loan that Joe Biden gave him
it would be a little more than 200 Grand
that would be called what's it what's it
called
interest that's the whole reason why we
laughed at you when you guys released
that [__] check that was for 200
Grand
even you re understand this Jason the
reason why we're laughing at you is
because when we look at it we go oh oh
yeah okay he paid him exactly 200 Grand
and he paid him back exactly 200 Grand
which means Joe Biden didn't charge him
any interest which means Joe Biden
didn't make any money off the loan
because that's how you make money
loaning money is
interest holy [__] how in the [__] do
they they listen to this again this is
on Fox News this is their business
correspondent Marita
bomarito and Jason Smith is the he's on
the house Ways and Means Committee
he's the chairman folks I do you know
what the house ways mean committee is do
you know what the Ways and Means
Committee is do you know what it
is you're not gonna believe it you're
not gonna believe it it is the committee
that is in charge of overseeing the tax
code oh my
god oh man
and this [__] guy listen just listen
listen to him but if you look at the
president's tax returns that he that he
has released publicly there's no
documentation of any interest income
that he has received for any loans that
he had granted towards anyone so we
answers to those questions make no you
don't being accurate on their tax forms
you don't need answers to those
questions because you provided us the
proof dum
dum these idiots just can't stop
stepping on rakes that's why when that
[__] check when the oversight
committee released that check you
remember the $200,000
check and I brought it up on the screen
I'm like I'm so excited about this these
[__] idiots look at this [__] what a
bunch of Dum
Dums if Joe Biden was gonna charge James
Biden his brother any interest James
Biden would have had to
give him
money and there would be evidence of
it they only have evidence of no
interest being
paid which is the same evidence that
they have from the public tax returns
that the president of the United States
this guy the current one not the [__]
last one because he couldn't release his
tax returns by but the current run has
released publicly the evidence that you
provided only backed
up what it says in the tax
return you people are providing the
evidence that Joe Biden is not the
criminal you say he
is and then you go on Fox News and act
like it is evidence of the opposite but
if you look at the president's tax
return go look at them Jason that he has
released
there's no documentation any income that
he has received for any loans that he
had granted towards anyone so we need
answers to those questions to make sure
that people are being accurate on their
tax forms oh oh okay so are you going to
have a Committee hearing to prove that
Joe Biden is a tax fraud I can't wait
for that
one I can't wait for it let's do do that
dumb Dums Jason hold a committee in the
ways and means accusing Joe Biden of
being a tax cheat please please I beg
you please I beg you do that and the
reason why I beg you is because
Democrats will get time in that
Committee hearing to show how Donald
Trump is in fact a [__] tax cheat
it's the reason why Donald Trump is on
Civil Trial in New
York and about to lose his entire
[__] shitty ass business that he's
[__] convinced all these people that
is worth all kinds of money and it's
not you [__]
bonehead don't stop stepping on
rakes don't
stop and this is the kind of
[__] that you got to point out to
him gotta point it out because it's very
rare that these
Republicans get to the
truth there's one this week that got to
the truth on Face the Nation his name is
Ken Buck I don't know what the [__]
happened to Ken Buck I have no [__]
clue I don't know if someone came to Ken
buck and threatened his [__] life and
it pissed Ken Buck off or what I don't
know what it was but some piss Ken Buck
off and Ken Buck is no longer going to
sit back and tell lies that he's been
telling for years which again we
shouldn't [__] Kim Buck okay [__] Kim
Buck Kim Buck is a goddamn Trump
apologist for for so goddamn long up
until this
point up until this point but here's Ken
Buck keep going I have everybody who
thinks that the election was stolen or
talks about the election being stolen is
lying to America
that's everyone um that that is that is
making that argument everyone who makes
the argument that January 6th was uh you
know unguided tour of the capital is
lying to America everyone who says that
the prisoners who are being uh
prosecuted right now for their
involvement in January 6th uh that that
they are somehow political prisoners or
that they didn't commit crimes those
folks are lying to America as a
Republican party if we're going to offer
good solid policy answers so the the the
real challenges we face in America we've
got to get past the lies and we've got
to have credibility with the American
public oh good luck with that Cynthia
points out that Ken Buck is isn't
running for reelection which that that
that is one Colonel but you know I'm I'm
wondering why he's not running for
reelection why is he not running for
re-election why has Kim Buck all of a
sudden decided to get right with the
truth is it because Ken Buck likes the
truth no
[__] no the [__] out of here with that
[__] he doesn't like the truth the same
way Liz Cheney didn't like the truth for
days I don't believe that the reason why
kin buuck is saying the truth is because
he's not
running I think he's not running and
he's saying the truth because of
something happened I think I think that
Ken Buck was
threatened and I think it pissed Ken
Buck off I think someone came to Ken
buck and said hey if you don't get on
the Trump train you're done [__]
not only you done your family's done
blah blah blah and they [__] did the
whole Mafia thing stupid [__] [__]
and it pissed him
off it pissed him the [__]
off Beyond any kind of [__] any any
kind of office or any kind of position
Ken Buck is is wealthy Beyond Your
Wildest Dreams he's got enough [__]
money him and his grandkids and everyone
else they'll be
fine they'll be
fine but why is Ken Buck getting with
the truth all of a sudden why now I
think it's because he was
threatened I think his life was
threatened and it was a serious [__]
threat and it came all the way from the
top down to Ken buck and it was obvious
who the [__] it came from and Ken Buck
was like [__] him because these people
don't like that [__] that's
that's the [__] lie that's the big
[__] lie that's why the boo thing in
South Carolina is one of our best
[__] ammunitions that we got against
these [__] idiots is because the real
big lie the [__] actual big Li is
people like that piece of [__] nobody
likes that piece of [__] trash no one
likes
him no one [__] likes him they all
want to boo him I mean there's 10 12%
there's the true cult
members that are [__]
delusional that it's become their
religion but the majority of people hate
that [__] they are sick of his
[__] [__] even if they voted for him
twice they're sick of his [__]
[__] they're tired of
trump it's enough already get the [__]
out of here no one wants to [__] hear
your
nonsense and it's the reason why we
should try to get him
upset we should get him upset just like
Ken Buck is
upset we should get him pissed
off and we should keep them pissed off
and the boo thing I know the booing
thing seems kind of you know childish or
whatever I don't give a
[__] it pisses them off because it gets
to the core that no one likes that
[__] what you're saying about
how people like him and he's the most
popular prison of all time that's all
[__] lies you know it's lies I know
it's lies everyone else knows its lies
no one likes that son of a [__] and
this was the little fight that I had on
Twitter over it I this person I don't
know this
[__] this troll bot says you've been
touting this boot off football fields
across X today which I was on Twitter
not on X dumb [__] and I tweeted like
one time I tweeted it like one time I
really wasn't on social media that much
over the weekend the troll goes on to
puke up but you keep neglecting to
mention that it's around a handful of
band nerds when the rest of the
thousands of people in the stands are
cheering your false narratives are are
weak that's what he
said and it really hurt my
feelings oh
man it hurt my feelings and then you'll
never believe what Elsie said oh my God
this is so
incredible the thing that he said next
just really melted my
heart cuz he said it was the
truth cuz I was lying and then he said
you're going to have a great January
20th
2025 that's what this troll said here's
what I told him I said I will that's the
day I've got penciled in to [__] your
mom in celebration of Brandon's win she
can't wait for me to trounce her like
Joey is gonna trounce the traitor you
love so
much this is how you treat them this is
how you bait them this is how you
[__] dunk on them this is how you do
it I really seriously doubt that this
troll will ever ever come back to my
[__] account
ever you burn them to the [__] ground
on their
[__] because the fact of the matter
is is that I am G to have a great
January 20th
2025 their
trollbot because people hate that guy's
[__]
guts and I'm going to stoke it and I'm
going to [__] lean into it and I'm
going to get people to engage in their
democracy I'm gonna get people out there
and get them active and involved I'm
gonna get them to use the
battle of the
ballot to win against this piece of
[__] trash and I will celebrate on
that day I will [__] celebrate on
that day that I have penciled in to [__]
this Troll's mom because I can't wait oh
my God I can't wait for Brandon to
trounce Donald Trump and I can't wait
for tomorrow I can't believe it's been
two hours I made it I made it with my
voice intact I didn't know if I could do
it and I'm glad you were here with me
today as you are every single weekday
Monday through Friday noon Eastern 11
Central 9 Pacific on YouTube twitch and
sometimes Facebook I promise I'm going
to try to get Facebook fixed maybe maybe
they'll let me back on maybe they'll get
me out of Facebook jail maybe you could
get me out of Facebook jail but until
then same time same place tomorrow surf
up
[__] you've been listening to
the Tony Michaels podcast in your face
commentary of current events and
political news no rules No Boundaries I
think we've made that perfectly clear we
hope you enjoyed the show and we'll be
back soon in the meantime follow Tony on
social media at the Tony Michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after
me [__] them [__]
[Music]
them Murphy's me born head ass
speaking
[Music]
[Applause]
w
[Music]
go